we were talking about the Middle East
and we have another story which I find
fascinating is the mayor of Miami has
asked for a U.S led intervention into
Cuba did you hear this no I didn't but I
think the last time we tried that it was
something to do with uh with pork belly
pigs pigs yeah well so so we got these
big protests erupting in Cuba I love
this one they're yelling Freedom down
with dictatorship and what does the
media say protesting you lack of covid
resources and vaccines and things like
that of course they have to spend this
because remember it was Barack Obama
down there with the castros at a
baseball game and he also took a big
picture in front of a mural of Che
Guevara one of the most bloodthirsty
revolutionaries ever yeah super racist
wasn't he yeah
and and so they can't they can't say
that uh people want freedom people want
Liberty now now it's about covet they
don't have enough Mass they need more
more vaccines you see they said uh New
York Times said freedom and other
anti-government slogans is that
incredible but but I do think that's
funny because
I think from a Libertarian perspective
you get it especially an anti-communist
perspective yeah saying freedom in Cuba
is anti-government see the thing is that
just the same as we saw in the Rio
Grande Valley in in Texas where
Hispanics want Safety and Security they
don't want defunding the police they
they they want their principles and
values are conservative you're going to
lose just the same as what happened in
the last election cycle the Cuban
community that that Hispanic Community
now in South Florida the Venezuelan
expatriates the Cuban ex Pacers they
went heavily for Donald Trump guess
what's going to happen this time they're
going to go even more so in the next
election and now here's why you're
familiar with the Democratic socialists
of America yes so the Democratic
socialists of America international
committee tweeted out in support of the
Cuban Communist Regime now here's the
best part it confused a lot of people
because they don't understand the
language of Communists yeah they tweeted
DSA stands with the Cuban people and
their revolution in this moment of
unrest and the blockade
what you need to understand about the
Communists is that they call their
government the revolution for instance
when I was in Venezuela they said Tim
Poole was sent here to destabilize the
revolution
they call their communist government the
revolution so when they tweet this out
saying they stand with the people and
their Revolution what did the president
of Cuba just say he said he was calling
on the Revolutionary citizenry to fight
back against the the protesters
this is the Democratic socialists of
America international committee with a
pinned tweet saying they support the
Communist Regime here's the best part
AOC as most of you know is a
card-carrying member of the democratic
socialists of America
a lot of people are pointing out that
Bernie AOC the squad aren't criticizing
the Cuban regime right now of course so
what do you think is going to happen you
saw what happened in that in that
Democrat District in 20 in 2020 in Miami
it was a safe Democrat District they
predicted it was going to swing you know
was it like 15 points or whatever
Democrat went hard red Republican won
and everyone kind of threw up all the
Democrats throw up in their muzzle like
how did this happen it's because these
people who live in Florida know exactly
what's going on in Cuba and exactly what
these promises really mean there was one
viral video from a Venezuelan couple a
year or so ago where she was like
everything the DSA AOC and Bernie
Sanders have promised you was exactly
what they told us in Venezuela and now
we're starving our Industries are
collapsing crime is skyrocketing once
the most prosperous nation in South
America now it's just the the shell of a
cell
murder more murder than any other way
how did it start what did one of the
first things that Hugo Chavez did he
banned private gun ownership oh wow
always oh yeah never let them always
that's where it starts you know you can
Bolshevik Revolution you know in in
China with Chairman Mao wherever you go
and it's always interesting how the left
you know it was the Democratic People's
Republic of Korea or is the Democratic
uh German uh Republican things of this
nation they always try to use that
Democratic word but yet they are the
progressive socials they are the status
they are the Communists they are the
marxists and we've got to get smarter
than that but think about this also when
Hamas was raining down Rockets all over
Israel drill you had you know the
members of the squad and others in the
Democratic party condemning Israel
and so there go there's going to come a
time when people they're our best
advertisement I guess that's what I want
to say and all we've got to do is voices
like you all's here and others just
continue to say this just the same as
they have that constant pressure instead
of the constant Retreat on our side we
have to match it with the constant
pressure of the truth that's what I'm
talking about that's why I say free the
code a lot I'm trying to create new
memes because being like no they're
wrong is just going to empower them and
that's what Republicans do all the time
instead of Republicans saying here's
what we want and why they say no to
Democrats yeah Michael Mouse brought
this up he said you've got Democrats
that are saying we want Universal Health
Care we want you to give to us and the
Republicans say no where's the
Republican to come out and say I want to
repeal the the NFA or repeal some of
these gun laws or to to say we want a
law that does X for us on gun rights
typically they're resisting Democrats
offense always on the defense you know I
give you a great example and I was
sharing this with some folks at CPAC
yesterday remember the the Olympic
Hammer thrower who came out she turned
her back on the national anthem area
yeah wouldn't it be great if someone
just came out and put a a little mean
just a side-by-side comparison
of Jesse Owens in 1936
standing on that pedestal after winning
the gold medal and saluting while the
national anthem was being played Munich
Germany in 1936 you know who was the
chancellor of Germany right then oh yeah
Adolf Hitler and then just at the bomb
says who's the real hero and see that's
how we deconstruct everything that they
say that just like right now with this
mandatory vaccinations let's just take
their language and say my body my choice
people have been doing that I love it
yeah Candace Owens tweeted something
about how her family has decided you
know what's best for them and people
called her her pro-choice and I I just
look at this and I'm like
here's what happens you get these young
people they have no political experience
they see some older person say here's
how you respond to it but it's
nonsensical the left either is lying or
doesn't understand that conservatives
argument is there are two people
involved in the in in one body with when
it comes to pro-life yeah and if if
Canada someone says my individual family
member made a choice she's not deciding
for another life it's like they don't
they don't understand anything that
conservatives say and it's probably
because they are just in this isolated
bubble they don't they don't talk
they're in the Box Echo chamber right
they're in their own Echo chamber and
and that's why it's so important to
understand that when they start to yell
and scream at you when they're starting
to call you the names instead of
retreating remember what Iran said the
constant Retreat you've got to you know
more constant pressure because you're
winning the debate you have taken them
past their initial little talking point
which is an inch deep and you need to go
on the office but too often what we do
is when they call us the name we go on
on the defense which emboldens them and
gives them the power and we see Power
and we see that over to them but we've
got to be more aggressive and continue
to pound them with the truth yeah that
that's why the critical race Theory
stuff is really effective it's it's
funny I mean we're talking about the
stuff in schools Christopher rufo has
been leading this charge James Lindsay
as well and they start screaming no
one's teaching critical race there you
get John Leguizamo coming out being like
yo this is just a a legal talkie talk or
whatever and it's funny because someone
I saw someone on Twitter point out if
you've got a problem with us calling
everything critical race Theory it's no
different from you calling everything
white supremacy so welcome to the same
game you've been playing absolutely and
they hate it but you know what is
interesting that completely debunks what
they're saying is that when the head of
the American Federation of teachers
Randy Weingarten stands up and says we
are going to teach critical race Theory
and we are going to go after parents who
try to you know stand up against us so
in other words what the teachers unions
the left has decided is there have
initiated a war on parents now remember
the war on women why don't we come out
and say there's a warm parents there was
a war on parents to make sure that their
kids are getting a good education and
not an indoctrination especially in your
Urban you know school districts where
kids are reading at level kids aren't
doing math at level but what do they
want they want to teach them that well
in
lit the see I'm going so far Lydia yeah
Ian Lydia and Tim
you're pressing me oh I'm not yeah you
are no I'm actually never stop Alan no
no no no no no you're not your skin is
white man nope nope so so no you're
oppressing me no you're not serving no
you're trying to put it on me no you're
impressing me I'm a victim
that's how I see it but that's what
critical race theory is saying to me
absolutely but now now you're telling me
I'm a Vic now I'm a victim of you
telling me I'm I'm oppressing you now
I'm the victim no no never ends it's a
cycle no no no in critical race you're
stuck in it oh no critical race Theory
it's actually fairly simple
you as a conservative instantly become a
white supremacist now as for me and
that's true and also Joe Biden said that
since I didn't vote for him I'm not
black so guess what I am screwed I'm
just like you guys now now check us out
though dang I'm just as white as living
the reality is for both of us if we
agree with them then we're both
oppressed
if we disagree with them then we're both
racists and our backgrounds don't matter
or anything like that but do you
understand how confusing that is so just
teach your kids math and reading and
stop screwing around with their minds
and trying to indoctrinate them but the
great thing Tim is that when you talk
about this critical race Theory two
years ago no one knew who their school
board member was yeah no one went to
school board meetings no one even cared
who is that thanks for checking out this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time